hey y'all it's undercat here in this
tire tuesday video
we're gonna continue our project from
scratch creating a ufc sports betting
model
and my previous video uh we did the data
scraping and data cleaning part
and now we're gonna focus on the feature
engineering and modeling
but before i start this video i want to
go over a few things
um one i have a q a video uh coming up
probably in about two weeks so
um if you want to ask me any questions
for that q a video please click on the
google drive link and submit a question
also
um so i usually record these videos in
advance and when i was doing the actual
modeling part
i completed it on monday but when i
loaded it up today
after work i saw that the model's files
were actually corrupted
specifically the rds file so i actually
have to rerun it all over again
unfortunately which is not great
but for this video i i've wanted to
mostly focus on the modeling um concepts
and modeling frameworks
and not the actual like um results for
the models so
um although it kind of is um
disappointing for me just because i
wanted to kind of show you all the
results from all these models
um but i started from scratch but um
for right now for this video i don't
think it's really gonna impact it
and maybe i'll go over the actual model
results in our next video which will go
over the actual
deployment and dashboard creation so
that's a little disappointing but
i'm still going to go over the feature
engineering and actual modeling
but we might not see as many results and
we'll be focusing mostly on
more of the frameworks and the kind of
thought process
that goes behind the actual modeling
standpoint
so um i don't think it's too big of a
deal but
unfortunately i screwed up and i messed
up my component models and i have to
retrain them again but uh that's fine
um so let's actually go over the
featured engine part so
if you if we remember from our previous
my previous video we
basically scraped all of our data
cleaned it up
and we selected some relevant stuff that
we wanted to mess with
so i'm just going to go line by line and
just kind of see what
can explain what i was doing so
obviously i just load in our
you know our fight data that was all
cleaned up
and basically this entire feature
engineering script
is like one or two code chunks and the
main ideas behind
um these features that i wanted to
create was we basically want to have
like
you know your basic fighter um
statistics and analytics and stuff like
that so like
you know the average punch is thrown
average punch is landed
um total strikes absorbed in his entire
career
um stuff like that so that's pretty
easy stuff to implement but one of the
things i think was interesting that i
wanted to add is
some just some helper functions so when
we're creating
these models we want to make sure we
don't have any data leakage
so if i'm trying to predict a fight i
don't want to include
the strikes thrown for that fight to
predict the outcome
right um so that's not going to happen
already that's not that's not going to
happen instead we're actually going to
use this model to do like hypothetical
things
so for example for this next saturday
it'll be gilbert burns versus kumar
guzman
and we don't want to use you know the
kumar uzin
versus governs fight to predict the
actual outcome if we don't if we've
never observed it
uh so that's why i use a bunch of lag
functions so
just taking the fighter's previous fight
that we have observed
to use as like an input okay so that's
just kind of to prevent a lot of data
leakage so
most of these functions are kind of
being wrapped around a lag function
so i created a lag sum and also a lag
mean
so let's actually start going into the
code
so we have a fighter table
i'm i'm trying to create which will
basically combine head-to-head
um stuff so an opponent and a fighter
um i obviously do some you know just
some data cleaning just to convert to
um ones and zeros just in case if i need
to do anything
um one of the things i also added was i
want to basically
uh consider a fighter being different
when they're in a different weight class
so i think if a
fighter drops down or goes up weight
class the general fighting
style changes a little bit so for
example for bantamweights or
the 135 pound guys they're gonna be
throwing way more volume
than say a heavyweight fighter right so
stuff like that where i base have it
grouped by fighter and weight class
instead of just fighter
i also arrange it by date uh since we're
going to use these cumulative functions
that i figured it would be usb a little
bit easier um just to make sure there's
no
weird window functions going on
so i create basically um
some win features um one of the win
features that they had
was that we could basically have like
win by um
tko win by decision etc but this
basically
converts as like a one hot code one hot
encoded feature
or just essentially assign a one and
then i pivot
wider where it's saying that okay
whatever value they have we're gonna say
that's a one
and for the remaining uh values or
remaining options that you can win or
always buy
we're just going to replace it with zero
nothing too crazy
and then we start we start doing is you
know we do our lag functions where we're
basically summing up
our cumulative wins and losses i type
okay one of the things that we also have
is like number of fights since we have
to
always consider or think about
how we're all doing we're always using a
grouped
um data frame and one
i think one of the problems with this
entire feature engineering pipeline
is that it's doing a lot of uh most of
the manipulations that goes into
the actual feature engineering is a
group by um and that can basically slow
the actual um function um severely so
this is actually a very slow script to
run
um when you consider that a lot is just
doing basic lagged human function and
stuff like that
so one of the first things i did was you
know total wins total losses
full rounds so someone has fought a
bunch of rounds you could see that
you know maybe that they're kind of more
of a veteran it could be facing they
have more experience etc
and obviously since we're going to be
using um some more non-linear models
that
you know we can actually have some type
of thing where you know up to a point of
total rounds or
up to a certain amount of seniority we
can see that you know the the fighter is
more likely to lose so
if fire is fought like you know 300 or
400 rounds
uh he's probably he or she is probably
an older person and it's probably going
to be retiring soon
so the model could see that and say oh
they might have less output thrown
or they're just more likely to lose okay
so again i created your generic damage
features so it's saying like
total strikes absorb total knockdowns
total significant strikes absorbed
all these things that you know i think
it's pretty straightforward it's it's
something where like yeah
a fighter is gonna have a bunch of
damage throughout their career
and i think that damage can have some
impact in the future
uh so just having these like total
damage few uh features
i thought was pretty um useful
so a bunch of it was just you know
summing everything up and then creating
some proportions so like
strike accuracy signature strike
actually take down accuracy
um just see like okay when they when
they go for some type of offensive
maneuver
how likely or what's a probability
observed
percentage observed uh actually landed
so we could see someone who's like you
know someone has a high amount of
strikes attempted the high probability
of landing
you know as a volume striker and they
can be a little better than you know
someone else
um there were some missing values just
because we're using like some lag sum
um so we i we just converted to zero i
did 0.0 because they were
like doubles and um that could help kind
of circumvent that data type
additionally i wanted to see like okay
if a fighter
has outstriked his past fighters let's
see like let's just calculate their
differentials
we're just trying to calculate you know
the total strike differential
the average differential just to see
like how good is this fighter you know
uh one of the things that we talked
about i guess in ufc is you know you
you want to hit someone and not be hit
so that's kind of just measuring out the
differentials
and then we also have like a day since
last fight feature i'm not sure how
actually useful this is um
but you could say that you know a
fighter hasn't fought in a long time
uh they could be rusty so they could
have like less output or if a fodder
a fighter fought really recently that
could impact
him with like the weight cut and stuff
like that
again then we do uh we remove like
rounds time date last fight date
um just because we don't want to
incorporate that into the model and then
i use a mutate across um and this is one
thing that i wanted to add
um instead of just having a simple
average which we have been doing already
um i wanted to do some type of weighted
average um and this
in this case i think this could be
definitely um i
changed it a little bit so the idea is
you know
maybe we're going to have more of a way
towards some a fighter's most recent
fight
right no a fighter is is as good as his
last fight
so we add a weight basically to um the
the um the features or significant
strike attempts against excited etc
all these offensive generic ufc metrics
um so i added a lag basically to it
um we have um and everybody said like
okay we have like the
this lag three so if there's no if that
fighter hasn't fought three times
or if the fighter has fought three times
or stuff and stuff like that and we
apply
different lagged formations if there is
just like only one previous fight
they'll just give it the default right
so he's just kind of saying that like
how many times has this fighter fought
um and if he or she hasn't fought three
fights how can you adjust this
this weighted metric um ideally i think
this model works probably the model that
we're creating or
that i want to create is basically going
to be more about
more experienced fighters so for me
personally i would probably just filter
it towards you know
on main card fights so on a main card
fight if you're fighting on the main
card
generally you have fought a few fights
to make it onto it
or like michael chan or who got traded
into it so for that i think
that way we'd have more information
additionally if you have a main card
fight
fighter who doesn't have a lot of data
um i'm sure this model
that we're creating is gonna under um
estimate that fighter just because
there's not a lot of information on a
fighter
and uh and it doesn't it's not and the
fighter's not really in our data source
that we're currently scraping
so i could incorporate like bellator and
stuff like that
but for me um just because this this
this entire video series is about like a
simple project
i've basically only worked a few days on
a few like a few nights on i'm after
work so i don't want to
put too much i don't say i don't want to
put too much effort into it but it's
something where
the amount of effort i put into it kind
of defeats the point of
this entire video where i really want to
teach you know what the thought process
is of the
not only about creating great fantastic
oracle
538 cell product more about you know
getting into it
and showing how to create a little side
project like a resume
for a student all right with all that
rambling aside
we're going to go on to these um
these features that are also created so
these are just basic
lagged features so i just say like okay
what was the previous fighters
um um uh strikes thrown and stuff like
that so
i also wanted to basically incorporate
some ar
models into it so this this entire model
has a bunch of like
you know moving averages um total
intercept averages
you know and then it also has a lagged
um features so it's kind of like an arma
style forecast where it has all these
different components you may also notice
that
we're actually creating like a lot of
components
for this model like if we were to create
like a linear regression for this model
it would definitely not be great because
all of these features can be correlated
there's a high dimensionality um and
it's something that you know i it's not
made for
you know your traditional when you're
linear regressions or logistic
regressions well i guess you could
probably do a logistic regression but
it's something where what we want to do
is start creating a bunch of these
features that we have a hunch
that would be you know kind of uh useful
for predicting things
so that we can then regularize and and
kind of remove some features that we
only need
so with with that being said we
basically did all of these things where
we basically created
your generic totals your averages
percentages your differentials your
weighted averages
and your lagged features okay so that
being
so that's all uh good and then we just
kind of ungroup it
you know we remove some things that we
don't need which these things are the
fight
are the actual values that happened in
that fight that we're actually trying to
predict
like outcome strikes you know takedown
submission attempts etc these are things
that we actually want to use
or we want to predict so we don't want
to have this into our
on all data yet and then we do that so
right here as you can see we have all of
these um features
about like what is 143 i guess
and you might be a little worried see
that all these are zeros because these
are their first fights so
if it's your first fight your average is
obviously not going to be
um greater than zero so there's all
zeros
so stuff like this where we have a bunch
of zeros
that's something where i would consider
just removing these and just having like
some type of filter where
we're gonna require um to be in the
model and to be predicted you might have
to have like three or four fights
okay one of the things that i actually
think um adds a lot of
value or one kind of different take on
your traditional um ufc models that you
see on like kaggle
is i i added an elo feature so since we
have some experience with
elo the elo package from my previous ufc
videos
i decided to actually use that video and
kind of um
run an elo model and then use those
elo values as a feature for our data
what that means is i think this is good
because we already have a bunch of auto
regressive features with the lag values
and we also have like the total wins
but one of the things that we really
want to i guess measure empirically is
how how how great were these wins for
this fighter right
if a fighter beat a guy was he expected
to beat that guy
um and that's why i wanted to add an elo
model
into it so that we have some type of
measurement of it
so generally what we also want to do is
based kind of like outperform the eo
model at least
so if our model isn't outperforming an
ewo model
then our model is basically pointless
because an ewo model takes about five
seconds to run
um so that's one thing that we kind of
want to add it was just kind of
ensemble and ewo model that way we can
quantify how good our fire is
how well the fighter can upset fighters
and when he when
he or she beats a fighter how how much
better
was that fighter or how great of a win
was it
so that's what i have right there and
then we now we have 145 features so we
added a few more
um which i believe was just like elo i
think it's just you oh right
yep um and then ego change so it was a
previous change
stuff like that and finally what we do
what i did was basically since this is
just one fighter's metric so
each fighter has about 145 features um
we're basically going to combine them
with each other so
the fighter and opponent are going to be
doing the head-to-head table
stuff like that um again
we also said okay obviously a fighter
cannot fight him or herself
remove the weight class opponent weight
class and opponent res
i kind of want to still include the
weight class um i might
include it in the model um but once we
actually get into the modeling
standpoint i'll show you why it's not in
there
but we can if i don't like the actual
component results i'll probably add
weight class because i think weight
costs
could add um maybe some some help to the
model but
to be honest i think one feature out of
all these other features
might not add that much effect
especially weight class i'm not exactly
sure
so i added some more differentials now
that we have our elo data
or our elo feature we can say that you
know if one
one fighter has a higher elo and that
person is favored
so that is a good feature to have you
know if someone if a person has
a higher ego score they're more likely
to win
you can also calculate the differential
to basic be like
oh how how much more likely is it is it
that fire gonna win
we also have like the differential
between the number of fights
so if one fighter has more fights than
the other they're more likely to be like
a veteran
and then we combine the eo equals
together and calculate the eol
probability
just to you know skip some steps in case
if our model can't calculate it
itself um i also created a few metrics
um by hand
that i thought were interesting so the
strike metric
opponent strike metric it's essentially
saying like oh if someone
uh it's kind of calculating using a
laplace transformation
uh from the like strikes landed versus
strikes received so like laplace
direction on the strike differential and
then also multiplying it by
how many kos or tko's the fighter had so
the striker outstrikes um usually
outstrikes his or her opponent
and has a lot of wins by tk uh tko or ko
okay if they can outstrike their
opponent really well and they're more
and they have a lot of knockouts
they have a high strike metric um and
then i calculate the differences
between the strike metrics and then i
have to strike favor so if someone has a
higher strike metric
um then they're favored additionally i
also have like some submission
metrics just because i think submissions
are a little bit more interesting so
you know if they take down uh if they
have a high amount of takedown so if
they're
really uh good at taking people down and
they have a lot of wins by submission
they have a very high submission score
right and
also they i i also kind of combined the
takedown defense
um with their loss submission so they
haven't lost a lot
um if they like say if they've never
lost by submission
and they've defended a lot of their
takedowns that's very good for our
submission metric
okay so basically create some strike a
strike metric and a submission metric
just to measure just how good of a
striker they are how good how good are
they at submissions
uh just to kind of think about you know
maybe these are some interesting
features to add
into a model just to do some feature
engineering and some interactions
and that's basically it uh so this is a
a bit about a 298 column
uh a table there's 11 000
about actually about 12 000 fights you
also have to know that these fights
are duplicated so it's there's a fighter
an opponent but these opponent
and fighters will switch we have to keep
that in mind
when we're actually doing the modeling
um
so that's basically it for the feature
engineering that was kind of my entire
mindset
um i don't think it was too crazy of a
future engineering
um mostly just like you know doing your
totals your averages
your weighted averages your
differentials and then you kind of do
some kind of cool interaction metrics um
additionally we also have incorporated
some elo models to assess you know how
the quality of wins against his or her
opponent inequality losses
while using also like a baseline model
to predict the probabilities that could
also add some type of effect
into our downstream models
so that's basically it for the feature
engineering
okay now we're actually going in the
modeling part which i think the modern
part is the most interesting
so first let's actually kind of go over
like how could we
how would we approach this from a
modeling standpoint
um i think from a lot of the videos that
i've not a lot of videos a lot of the
you know the notebooks and scripts i saw
on kaggle because
you know creating a ufc model to predict
fights is not a new
concept you know same thing with like
predicting baseball wins or baseball
runs
um all these things centered around
sports is not a new idea
and chances are like i like you're not
going to be the first person to think of
a sports idea
in sports analytics um but that being
said
when i watch and we're going to read a
lot of these ufc
notebooks a lot of times what they do is
they scrape from ufc data.com
they grab everything they put it into a
little
tensor they use keras to predict
the outcome of the fight using binary
cross entropy
the sigmoid activation activation
function
um i think that's cool i think that's
fine um one of the problems with this
i think approach where you're
essentially creating a black box
oracle we're just shoving all these
features in
and having the model basically kind of
overfit and predict the results is
it's not a good way to model things when
you want to kind of validate it
what i mean by that is obviously you can
do some type of
um lime model and pdp model pdp bots
stuff like that
to gain some type of interpretability
from these neural networks
but it's not exactly the most it's
almost too direct where
you're having the model do all these
things that you can't really validate
and check
so for my approach um just to make it a
little bit more
interesting and i think because it kind
of adds a little bit more from and
builds upon what we've been doing
in my entire tidy tuesday series is
we're just gonna model out the
components
and use those components as an ensemble
to predict
the outcome um so we're actually going
to do a bunch of models
i still i'm going to use a bunch of
neural networks and i think one thing
that we can always do though
is you know putting all these putting
putting everything into
one tensor and then in a tensor format
and then
predicting an outcome like we see in all
these other kaggle books
is relatively easy like right we have
our fight data
it's already processed for that um
approach so if if anyone wants to do it
they should do it
it's i mean it's there for us to do it
so uh definitely
not saying you shouldn't do it it's just
something that i didn't feel like doing
for this project please frankly it would
only be this video would be five minutes
long
um so let's actually go over what i was
doing
even though with me being highly
critical about these modeling approaches
me screwing up the entire process and
having to restart this video
um restarting my entire training process
for these components where i would i
don't have it finished for my actual
video on
machine learning so that was a lot of
rambling but let's actually go through
this
so we're incorporating our fight data
our fights and our fighter tables
um these are just kind of our main
things that we want um the fight data
is you know the pre-process
feature-engineered uh data set
that we were kind of um was working on i
mean this is like the the
one that we're working on with our
future engineering and then we have the
actual fights which is
the processed um post feature
engineering data set
so one of the things i first wanted to
do was actually create
a components data set so what this
means is i'm basically trying to predict
um
certain components so what i want to
basically com what i basically want to
um predict for each fight
is you know knock downs significant
strike landed
strikes landed submission attempts take
down
uh take to take down um landed right so
i'm based trying to predict like
okay how many how many punches of land
is this fire gonna land when he's facing
this other fighter for this fight
um so i have his target components where
i basically say okay i'm gonna select
the fight pk
the fighter round finished
and also the things that we wanted to do
um i actually don't need these attempts
because i was think uh when i was
actually originally doing it i was
thinking
well maybe we can model the attempts the
landed
everything like that just to validate
just to make sure like you know our
attempts
are always higher than our landed but i
don't think that actually adds a lot of
value
for right now um so i want to just do
the actual landed part and for
submission attempts there's no
submissions landed because if they
actually
landed the submission attempt that means
they won the fight
okay so i actually can remove these
things but i'm just going to leave it in
just because like
this script is still going uh so i don't
want to bug that
okay so we have our target components
was which is essentially the thing that
we're trying to predict
um and then we have our in independent
or individual components
which is like the components that are
not the target right so all of the stuff
that we created from our future
engineering script is right here
did a few bunch uh you know did a little
bit of cleaning just converting things
to factors
also removing things into like if if
it's a zero it's like a
it's n a
okay uh i i mean i
replace any n a's with zeros sorry so
one things i did was i actually wanted
to create a
outcome model so one of the ideas right
is
you know instead of putting everything
together into a model
realistic we want to kind of replicate
the real world and if we think about
when we're assessing a fight or how uh
a judge uh a judge assesses a fight you
know if a fighter
outstruck his opponent his or her
opponent had more takedowns
you know had more knockdowns had more
segment strikes had more submission
attempts
the fire should win right the fighter
should win
so what i essentially did was just
created
a differential um um data set
so uh for the actual um
inputs so it's saying that i did a pivot
longer
and then i said okay we're just going to
calculate the fighters
um component values minus the opponent's
values that's like the differentials
right so it's saying like okay so this
diff is like
a strike diff so that means if it's
positive that means the fighter
struck had landed more strikes than hit
the opponent
additionally what i actually did um
let's see here
uh so that's basically all that stuff
where i just calculated the strike
differentials
or the the i guess the target component
differentials
for the fighters and the opponents i
also wanted to remove any matches that
resulted into
a tie i figured incorporating ties
inside a model um isn't really the best
idea
i don't think a lot of people predict
ties or draws because i think they're
relatively rare
in ufc so i just removed that
additionally with the data frame is
we know that um we have uh the opponent
and fighters have this pairwise
whopping effect where if fighter a is
fighting fighter b
those pairs will actually swap because
we have a duplicate so i basically
grouped it by each
individual fight and then sampled a
random fight from it
then i created you know again just doing
some um
factors stuff so saying like if it res
equals one
the win else it's a loss
okay and then one of the things i
also added just as a little feature just
because i think this will also help a
lot in the model
you're saying like let's count how many
times
the fighter uh has a higher differential
or
let's count the total components as a
fighter
um out struck or outperformed his his or
her opponent
isn't this entire model is trying to
predict the fighter's outcome not hit
the opponent outcome
so that's why it's we don't have like oh
we have uh we don't have
the opponent's total um
total advantage or total components that
they had an advantage on
so we say mutate across if it's greater
than zero that means
fighter outstruck or out you know out
out through um his or her opponent
but then it'll be like you know knock
down advantage
strike landed advantage and then what we
do is actually a row wise
um we use a row wise function for every
row we just sum across
all that stuff uh they get the total
count that's our above zero we could
also manually do it but
for me i think this is actually one of
more elegant ways to do it
i'm sure there's a better worldwide
function to do it but i actually don't
really use railwise a lot
okay again um i don't
really want to go too much into sorry
about that
i do like the tidy models part um i've
i've made a ton of videos on tidy models
i think
um obviously i'm gonna still go over but
i don't think i have to go too much into
into detail with it through my training
test splits using k volts cross
validation
create a recipe removing the fight bk
and the fighter
just do a yo johnson um normalization
with it
and then uh you know since this is a
classification so
we're basically using these strike
differentials
to predict the outcome of the fight we
have our axi roc
sensitivity sensitivity specificity mean
log loss
control grid saving the predictions just
to see
where the model went wrong stuff like
that
also diffuse some confusion matrices in
this case
i also wanted to use xgboost for the
classification i wanted to use xg boost
for all the models
uh really for no particular reason i
think actually
um i would probably change it to a
random force for the components models
just
because the actual component models have
a highly wide a very wide data set
um which will definitely benefit um
random fours more than
um xgboost but you know i'm not too
worried about it
um if i see bad results in my actual
tuning process i'll prob i might change
it to random forest
or something that you guys can do in
your own time
then i tuned the models and i saved the
outcome
um i actually saved all the outcomes
because i i was playing at the end of
the video to basically
evaluate all my models and basically say
okay here's our model performance for
this metric here's our model performs
for this component
etc okay so once we actually so right
here we basically finished our outcome
model
which uses the target which uses
basically uh
the differentials for that fight
to basically predict the outcome of the
fight so if this fighter outstruck
had more knockdowns had more takedowns
had more submission attempts
then that fire is more likely to win but
now what we're actually doing
which is probably the majority of this
actual um
script is now we want to actually
predict you know
a fighter's knockdowns for a fight
against another fighter right
um so we did that uh
i created my trained test splits for all
these components now we can see what
we're trying to predict we're trying to
predict
target knockdowns pertinent target sedan
historics landed
target strikes landed target submission
attempts target takedowns landed
and i totally did not go over one thing
i added
uh which is right here so one of the
things i was thinking about and one
things i actually messed up
uh while i was working on this script a
week ago
was i didn't really normalize our
targets and what i mean by that is
these targets are the entire total
fights um components so it's the total
strikes thrown in that fight um one of
the problems with this
is that fights end um vice can have
multiple rounds right so
if i could have three rounds or five
rounds additionally if a fighter knocks
another fighter out
it stops at that round uh so some fights
would have
way more strikes landed than another
fight
and i was thinking well we could um
model it out and just leave it like that
or what i could do is basically um try
to predict
the average um price landed for a round
right the average knockdowns per round
the average uh submission attempts per
round
so that's what i basically did right
here where i said okay
for all these um outcomes for the fights
we're gonna basically normalize
these um these uh components
by the total rounds that were actually
fought
so we're basically up we're trying to
predict the average strikes landed the
average knockdowns
the average takedowns for every fight
and then we can also multiply it
at the end like when we're starting our
dashboard so that's why we have like
target takedowns land or we're trying to
predict 0.5 right there's no such thing
as a half a takedown
um it's just because uh you know it went
two rounds
and there's only one takedown cool
so one of the metrics that we the
metrics set was rmse
mae r squared mipe smap
e but the main metric i'm really looking
at is rm
sc or root mean squared error um
for my tuning function i actually wanted
to go with the
um fine tune package because i was
pretty lazy about it and fear that you
know having simulated
annealing or whatever it's called would
be kind of beneficial for me
uh for this project just because i
didn't really need to
um define a parameter grid for all these
components
instead it could basically search for it
and it could stop early
if it found it so i basically defined
all these models
since they're since they're all using
the same data set
i didn't want it to include all of these
you know
um this data leakage right here where we
don't include the fight pk
the fighter you know the actual strikes
landed the actual strike significant
strikes landed for that fight
we want to remove that and then predict
you know total knockdowns
right um did you johnson
normalized one high encoded stuff
did the same for knockdowns significant
strikes strikes
mission attempts takedowns and we
removed all the things
um that were the targets besides the
target that we're trying to predict
obviously so that's basically it right
there
and then again to find another xg boost
model
in this case i think i wanted to try and
i still might do it i might try a random
forest model
and just because we can set um even
though it's obviously a tree based model
um i figured you know why not try random
forest because i think random forest and
xgboos
will generally have similar performance
um
with each other so there's no reason not
to try it and then i did
tune sim anneal with five iterations
uh using k folds cross validation and
i'm saving out all these outcomes right
here
so that is basically it for the xg boost
individual components models um
which i think if you actually look at it
it's i think it's pretty straightforward
i think it makes a lot of sense um these
were
based trying to output like each
individual's fighters um components
use that as a thing or the phone
for the use that to predict a fighter
and an opponent's
um strikes and knockdowns
calculate the differentials throw into
the outcome model to basically be the
judge and say
okay we see that this fighter outstruck
this fighter
we're gonna say that fighter juan all
right that way we can validate where
it's like oh hey like
why is it saying that desapoi is gonna
beat conor mcgregor
and said we could say because our model
is forecasting you know
just employee to have you know 20 more
segment strikes than conor mcgregor
or something like that but we also want
to do
some neural network stuff right
so with neural networks
did i do a few uh a little bit of
pre-processing
but not a lot so again we have our
inputs and our outputs
so in this case we have like our output
is we're trying to predict
knockdowns to give strikes strikes
submission attempts takedowns
and then our input is not anything that
has a target fight behavior fighter
and we do some pre-processing eo johnson
uh normalization then we do a step range
to convert it all
in between zero and one we just do dummy
one hot encoding
and then that's it okay then i basically
apply that matrix or
apply the preprocessing to the inputs
and outputs and convert it to a matrix
same thing for the outputs
so i define a basically basically a you
know your generic three layer
densely connected neural network file
using
atom mean squared errors are lost i want
to see the mean absolute error
and here's the one thing that we kind of
get into where
it's actually pretty interesting to do
some of these multi-header neural
networks because
instead of doing all these components
individually
i wanted to do it all these components
at once so we actually have
was at five nodes
right for our output and these nodes are
really predicting
our five components that we want to
predict but what we have to do is when
we're calculating
the mean absolute error we have to or
calculate the mean squared error
we have to realize that um these outputs
so knock downs significant strikes
landed submission attempts and takedowns
they are on different scales right so
if we're off by 30 or knock downs but
we're only off by
one for 600 strikes we're gonna have
that highly panel
it's going to basically have that base
of the same unless if we start weighting
things
but one of the things we have to think
about is you know what what thing we
want to really focus on
be highly accurate um for a modem
and one of the things i did was actually
looked at
my outcome model using the differentials
and basically looked at the variable
important so i saw that
right here
it's so with our differential model
talking all the differentials between
all the components i said what is the
most
um important variable for this component
and it said that basically um
significant strikes was the most
important component and
realistically that's something what we
would expect right if someone has a ton
of significant strikes
advantage or had 20 more significant
strike attempts
um then strikes landed then his his or
her opponent
the fighters can all win right so that's
basically what it added so i kind of
just
calculated a random weight and said okay
we want our significant strike
landed to be a very accurate
knockdowns you know we don't really care
that much you know we could say
um and then was the takedowns i said you
know what
maybe we'll we'll decrease that weight
um
this is something where i was like okay
this is completely arbitrary we just
want to kind of
you know make something up so i did that
and waited mostly towards
if it strikes landed um then it'd be
followed by strikes landed and then be
followed by was it
the mission attempts it's followed by
knockdowns and then takedowns
okay so then i fit it using a validation
split
um using early callbacks so the the
epics or epochs don't really
matter too much um basically it's saying
like if we don't see any
improvement after 20 epochs or epics
it's just going to stop early
cool i did that i thought that was okay
that's fine
um it worked this is mostly for
for actually seeing like oh how how well
does this multi-headed model work
um it worked i didn't run into any
errors
so then i started creating an actual
validation index
but using my training data i wanted to
create a validation split for our
training data
um because i didn't want to touch the
test data at all
and one thing i wanted to do now is
actually
basically tune these weights so you know
how how much should i
actually um weight my loss function to
each component
right so it created a function basically
to tune the keros weights
where it creates a model um where your
only input is a
is a vector of weights we say okay we
can give it any weight so
add weights to the outputs
and then what's actually doing is it's
using that validation data from our
training data
to basically predict the mean
absolute error for all the components
right so it's actually predicting on our
validation data that it's never seen
and then it's and then i'm calculating
the each component's
absolute average error or mean absolute
error
for each component right so
uh i did that um but one of the things i
was thinking about is well i need
how can i simulate uh five weights
where i want it to equal one right
um and that's like the dear sweat
distribution dear dear clay
i know it's like german french so i i'm
not i'm terrible at that
and then even though i took a year
french but it's like the deer shall
um distribution or just use the g2os
package to basically get
a vector of five values um randomly that
sum up to one
so i basically said okay we're gonna go
through this um
we're gonna simulate 50 random weights
um and then tune 50 models and a base
basically
at the um each components at
a mean absolute error right so then i
remove that
summed up the we also have these total
error so total absolute error
um and plot that out and what we
actually found
obviously is that um you know we want to
weight more towards
um these values again um so
instead of just having a uniform
uniformly random i want to add a little
bit more weight towards significant
strikes and also knock downs
had it simulate um and then we can see
right here the density
of our was it our error or whatever
um yep our total error um
and then we could see which um which one
had the lowest error
and these are the weights that i wanted
to use i guess for my actual
final model so instead we actually
changed more towards
v2 and v5
cool so that's basically how i simulated
it um
i just wanted to say like okay you know
what what's the mean absolute error for
all the components when we change the
loss um weight scheme
for all of our components right um so
that was a quick and dirty way
basically having some type of informed
decision
on assigning weights to our actual
um our actual model to predict
the um target um target components
and that to me it kind of makes sense
but also i'm a little fuzzy on it
because it's really assessing like each
component
um absolute error so how well it how
well a neural network can fit
uh to the actual component so how well
it can predict strikes thrown stuff like
that
it's not only doing like um total you
know the actual outcome
of the match right so right there i fit
my final model um where i basically want
to try out since i was basically using
i'm kind of all over the place i was
basically using you know a generic
three-layer 512 unit um wide neural
network which is
you know it's it's not you know it's
something where
if you had that you you wouldn't know if
there was a better model you you'd want
to always
tweak and see how well it works um with
different little
architecture so using the same weights
same training data same scheme for
callbacks and stuff like that i
essentially um created a few different
neural network architectures
one adding dropouts um
one just making it a little bit wider
and then one just
adding it making a little bit deeper and
wider right
so all that went down and i basically
recorded
i recorded all of it and saw that
the one the simpler model i guess had
a little bit better um what is this
actually i don't think i needed that let
me see
okay yeah so i found i think this model
had the best um
validation error using the validation
split um assessing mean squared error
so i just fit it using you know a
slightly wider model
with um with dropout
cool so one of the things i was also
thinking about
while making these models especially
with these multi-headed models is
so we have these mo this model
predicting five five features right it's
trying to predict
takedowns knockdowns submission attempts
strikes landed and significant strikes
landed
right all these are this is just our
simple regression problem
um five regression models basically
using one neural network
but i was also kind of thinking about
what if i did a different multi-headed
model
where instead of just trying to predict
these five components it also try to
predict the outcome
of the match right so
um while i was reading um was it deep
learning with r
um a lot of times they were talking
about like you know when you're trying
to predict
um predict you know the an image saying
like is this a dress is it a shoe
and also trying to predict the price it
was actually better to do
one model that we did that did both
things where it did both a
classification and a regression problem
setting have instead of having two
different neural networks to do
to do that um task so i thought okay
what if i just add in
the outcome of the fight and let's also
assess
um you know how well it fits you know
it'd be kind of cool if like it could
you know it could predict the components
better and also predict the
outcome better right that'd be that'd be
pretty cool if it if it did it so
that's what i did um i essentially
created another
output or instead of just having these
five components like target knocked down
sigma strikes
etc i also added the outcome convert
that to a binary outcome one zeros
and then convert it to a matrix okay
so did that for the train output and the
test output still going to have the same
inputs just kind of slightly different
outputs one of the things i had to do
though
is not use the generic high level
interface
instead had to go a little bit lower
level um
but it's still keras so it's pretty
pretty easy so it basically had to
define an input
um these inputs um we knew what our
input dimension was which is the
you know total columns of our input so i
just said where input
shape is equal to the total amount of
features that we're inputting
d type integer name fights
right this is our fight input um then i
define a base model in this case i want
to do
you know a three-layer neural network
and i wanted to add dropout
um i guess i also should say i use relu
activation functions for all my models
i think i've just always used relu
instead of like um
all the other things like with a softmax
and stuff like that
this off max it's the uh um
tan h instead of like tan h and stuff
like that um i've always just used relu
um i think when when i was reading more
about neural networks that was when it
was really
the regular activation function was
really in fashion so i just did that
and then i had to basically define all
of these outputs
so i said like okay for knock downs
significant strikes strikes submissions
take down i landed all these are just
one unit because it's a regression
problem
right um no activation because it's a
regression
but for the target res which is the
outcome of the
byte um it's still one unit but in this
case we have our ac we apply an
activation
which is a sigmoid activation because
it's a binary outcome
right so after that i have my input
which is
our fight input and then our
um and then our was it our actually it
should be a base model
um then our our base model
and then we add in our you know i'll
just oh no no it's fight input when
we're talking about
because of the base model these target
80s
are assigned to our base model right um
we have our input and then we have our
other what is it six models
kind of being as our uh outputs
okay um then i compiled it um i used
basically the same um weighting scheme
except i added a 0.2 to the results
um i also defined for a loss like all
will be mean squared error
except for our outcome our results which
is you know a binary outcome so we use
binary cross entropy
um so that was our how we defined it and
then lastly i just fit the model
um using all these inputs you know just
from saying that okay we want our
um i'll use our our baseline input and
then
our output would be our knockdowns from
our
output matrix and just like index so i
just had to say one two three four five
six
one two three four five six defined
um 500 epics a validation split of 0.2
so 80 20 split and then applied
early on callbacks that was basically it
for that model
yep and then what i was going to do
which i'm sorry
let me see if i actually have it nope
it's not done yet um
never strikes land and knocked down tune
yep so i have a few few more hours to go
so what i was going to do basically
assess all of the results for our models
i was basically going to say like okay
collect them one with the best rmse for
all these
models like the one the best rwc aoc or
accuracy
because i want to view the confusion
matrices see that
but i would just suspect it to be pretty
accurate just cause
um i think it'd be weird or someone did
basically out strike have more knock
downs and stuff like that unless it was
like a knockout i guess
uh which can happen um but generally i
wouldn't want to model that or like
overfit to that i'd be fine with
you know missing some from crazy
knockouts um so i was basically do that
for these
indiv video models and then
and then use my also my neural networks
and basically predict on the test set
um that we have that we all i think all
these models share
and using that test set basically
calculate which one
had a better rmse you know our actually
boost component models
or our first neural network that just
did the five components or our second
neural network that did defy components
and the outcome after that
get them together and save them as a
model file as an rds file
and then just continue on the uh the
actual
um app so i think for next video
i'm going to be focusing on creating a a
simple little dashboard
probably a dashboard similar to the
other dashboards that i've made
but also probably implement more of like
a pipeline and figuring out like
i guess it's mostly going to be
dependent on the models that we have but
you know adding some interactiveness so
allowing per a person to
select a fighter and another fighter and
count the probabilities
calculate spreads and also have like be
able to you know
go to another page and you know download
all their data
um their generic data and stuff like
that
so i know this video was actually very
long it's a 52 minute video where i
essentially talked and rambled through
it but i hope you liked it
um i'll definitely see you guys next
week for the app
and i'm definitely excited to get some
of your questions to answer for my q a
so with that being said uh i'll see you
guys next week and tidy on